comparisons to Pete Davidson I've gotten
that a lot I think it started in 2014 or
15. some would they asked like if you
ever get any comparisons and that was
like before Pete kind of took off and
then it kind of got back to him and he
came out the city field and we played
the Mets there dressed up as me and kind
of took BP the Marlins didn't tell
anybody that he was showing up they just
like rolled him out there they thought
it was like a plan or something Have you
ever had like a weird place that you
were like oh that's Pete Davidson every
night we play Somebody's screen so that
Pete Davidson at me especially on the
road do you see it or no we kind of both
agree that we don't really look too much
like each other